back in the day you know even
volunteering for the aclu in new york
city and being like i like this
organization i like these people they
stand up for free speech no matter who
it is
and they're fighting for individuals
liberties against the government
and and and literally i remember meeting
with them i'm spending my time as a
teenager
being like these are the good guys doing
something that's right and now
i mean you know and we know exactly what
happened what happened was
donald trump announced there was going
to be a moratorium on travel from
several
seven nations and the aclu all of a
sudden saw a massive
spike in donations they were suing
donald trump
so the left rallied around the aclu and
then the aclu defended the right of
these alt-right individuals in
charlottesville the right to hold their
event
and the left went how dare you and
started leaving the aclu in droves
so the aclu said hold on a minute guys
should we uphold our principles
or take money and they took that sweet
money
because they didn't want to offend all
those new donors who were pumping in
those bucks
so now they've gone from the american
civil civil liberties union to the
anti-civil liberties union literally
advocating
for censoring speech that's the opposite
of civil liberties
amazing the aclu that you were talking
about
in your past they got cancelled
yeah canceled and converted yeah so i'm
happy about that
it's it's infiltrate destroy rebuild
they they
the these woke cultists kick the door in
slowly start taking positions of power
and then once the the woke mob on the
outside cancels them
then the the woke people inside say see
here's what we have to do that's what
people want
when you see how to do it canceled were
they like does people resign
no i it's that political pressure they
can't look
there was you may recall you know none
of us were really around back then but
the like there's american nazi party
they would want to have a parade every
year
somewhere and locals would say we don't
really want that in our neighborhood but
then the seo would
aclu would show up and say hey they have
a right to political speech we're going
to defend it
that takes a certain level of courage
and fortitude
that that integrity from law students
through law schools to practice
is gone everybody is terrified of not
conforming to
this to what um is popular at the moment
and
and that the idea of somebody's
rebelling or standing up in opposition
to what
the the masses or the woke mob thinks
it's pretty much disappeared on the left
it doesn't
it kind of disappeared i think with um
justice kennedy because he was kind of
the leader of that
and well you know the problem is look
i get it collectivists are going to be
collectivists the problem is
there's no there's no counter to this
the republican party is basically the
you know old dotard sitting in a rocking
chair saying hold on there mister and
that's all they do
there's no one actually there's very few
i should say there are a lot of people
that are speaking out against this
there's intellectual dark web types
there's the
you know there are some leftists who are
anti-woke but for the most part
there's zero opposition and what you
have is a bunch of losers
who i love it when they when people i
know even some of my friends i'm very
disappointed in them
we'll be like i just can't stand all
this cancel culture stuff and this weird
like weird like these weird ideologies
they're pushing
and i'm like oh have you tried speaking
up speaking up against it oh no i oh no
not me i couldn't do that
well then shut up but don't complain
preemptively cancelled themselves
because of optics they don't want to
look this is this is
you know you can do it for those people
they'll drive them nuts is bring back
that old metaphor and say well
first they came for alex jones and you
didn't say anything
but they don't care but they love that i
love that
they i talked to i've got a bunch of
friends who are regular people and
they're just
terrified and spineless that's pathetic
and it's the definition of pathetic when
you care what other people think about
you you care what the audience thinks
that's not it's not that they care what
people think about them is that they're
like but i'll lose my job
they're like i can't speak out because
of what they'll think
people i love this because i've been
saying it for years they think
that as the woke mob goes door to door
kicking it in
and dragging people into the street they
say if i just don't say anything
my house will be the one they skip they
didn't skip any of the doors
they didn't skip any of the houses
they're going door to door after every
single industry
you will get cancelled period right
the only problem is you had an
opportunity to stand up and speak up and
you didn't do it
now i know a lot of people who watch
this show probably did because you know
if you're watching this you're probably
not happy with what's going on but too
many people don't they won't
and that's it there was a really
horrifying twitter thread from james
lindsay didn't you guys know james
lindsay yeah
he basically said it's over they won
there's no winning this fight
the best you can do is defend yourself
don't back down stand up what you
believe in and hope it doesn't last that
long but it could last centuries
yeah don't you fight it it's not a fight
to take you can circumvent the problem
and fix it from the outside without
engaging in it the problem is you know
even if you look at the american
revolution
most people like the plurality are just
scared and don't want to do anything and
that's really
really sad it is it's like you're
watching a forest fire
and there's someone saying if you and i
turn this hose on we can make it go away
and say but i might get burned
i'd rather back away and watch the force
burn to the ground
than do anything that brings risk to
myself and yet these people
reap the benefits of those who are
willing to sacrifice to make the world a
better place and that is one of the
biggest
biggest problems we face in this country
for the longest time it's always been
there's that meme of
there's this beautiful like there's this
like uh i don't know
i actually call it cliff there's this
like loving looking couple looking on
this beautiful city
and then underneath it's a bunch of
soldiers in the dirt holding them up
it's always been those who are willing
to sacrifice who provide for those who
aren't
yeah and that's and and people need to
accept responsibility for what's going
on that word sacrifice is like
is like muted it's been diffused the
power of the word what it really means
to sacrifice
your your well-being whether it's that
you're ridiculed in public or that
you have to suffer trauma by seeing
someone bleed out next to you like
that's
alters you forever it's not even that
it's that you might have to carry a rock
you might have to lift something what's
that you got to pick up a heavy box
you don't want to do it people would
rather just lay around and be like but
it's so
easy to do nothing and let evil people
destroy everything
what's the saying all that is required
for evil to succeed is good
is that good men do nothing it's martin
luther king right i don't remember is
that i think so yeah
famous quote shout out to martin luther
king but uh here we are
that's it what's the answer luke i'm
still i'm looking up chomsky
and seeing what he's up to because he
also a couple days decades ago was
very strong in favor of free speech and
standing up for everyone he has this
famous quote that i just looked up
that i i want to share with everyone and
he said quote goebbels was in favor of
free speech for views he liked so was
stalin
if you're really in favor of free speech
then you're in favor of freedom of
speech for precisely the views you
despise
otherwise you're not in favor of free
speech and i absolutely agree
with him and he was a major important
figure that was standing up for people's
individuals liberties
and speech no matter what it was and now
he wrote an article that is comparing
the coup
attempt being closer to the center of
power then hitler's 1920
yes chomsky this is truth out uh
i'm reading the article right now and uh
i'm still trying to get to the kind of
basis i was reading when you guys were
talking about
but essentially you know he calls what
happened a coup attempt
and he's comparing it to hitler's rise
in power well so you know i don't know
how to tell you man
you know i was talking to a friend of
mine earlier who just
they don't care time magazine puts out
an article where they're just laughing
in the faces of everybody
and these regular people are like well
you know i don't care
and i'm like have you asked yourself why
it is that
you're working two minimum wage jobs to
try and pay your bills
have you asked yourself why it is that
your business was shut down and you lost
your job for months
have you asked yourself why it is that
you're on your knees begging the
government to please cut you some scraps
and there are a lot of people who aren't
doing that
do you wonder why it is there are a lot
of people who are currently getting by
and doing just fine and you're the one
who is being subjugated
could it be that it's because the other
people have stood up
and walked away from this and found a
way to be responsible for themselves and
take care of themselves
but you just keep saying please let me
lick the bottom of your shoe
okay you know what i'll tell you this
you're under no obligation to lick
anybody's shoe
but if you really want to far be it from
me to stop you
so i'll be out in the middle of nowhere
kind of just doing my thing and talking
about what i want to talk about and
playing games and skateboarding and all
that stuff and if you really want to
live under the boots of these people
and you refuse to do anything about it
then don't expect anyone to come save
you when you get evicted from your
apartment you're living in the streets
that's what's coming next the moratorium
on evictions will end
soon these people haven't paid their
bills and there's been no covert relief
even if joe biden cuts these 1400 checks
it's not going to pay
the seven or eight months of back rent
these people are all gonna find
themselves in the street and the
democrats won't give you anything
they said they were gonna give you two
thousand dollar checks no no i'm sorry
that was supplemental that was only
fourteen hundred because you already got
six hundred right all right well
well that kind of makes sense then they
said oh and by the way we said everyone
we actually meant means tested so
if you make more than 50 000 a year
you'll still get evicted because your
cost of living probably is higher living
in new york city and you make too much
sorry goodbye the street is the place
for you are they measuring that 50 grand
based on last year's
thing so if you're unemployed right now
and you make it because if you're making
if you make 50 grand they start
diminishing your your uh
the students you're on a salary to
project it to make 50 grand this year or
is it like whatever
it's probably the previous year are you
sure because i swear repeatedly and over
and over again biden and his whole
campaign team were tweeting about no you
elect me
two thousand dollar checks right away
right that's a good point am i did i
imagine that
no you did not you didn't and how do you
say
this this means tested thing about 50
grand when it's like okay what if you
live in new york and what if you live in
omaha cost 3 000 a month in san
francisco
four years ago and and so the people in
new york who haven't been paying it
and the people in chicago and la who
they can't pay it
are sitting here licking the boots of
democrats saying
you know we're getting we're gonna cross
our fingers and hope this is the time
they give us what we need no they shut
your businesses down they took your jobs
away and then they gave you nothing
and now you're gonna get kicked out
you're gonna live in the street i keep
talking about
this rockefeller okay i don't know
enough about it to really pin this all
on john d
rockefeller but when they kind of
re-evolved the
school industry in the 1920s when they
were kind of attempting the coup
of the federal reserve and all this in
1910 1920
they built a new school system where we
raise our hands wait for the bell we're
basically learning to be factory workers
it might have been earlier than the 20s
i don't really know the details if any
of you guys do please please fill in the
gaps
but it seems like they they succeeded in
turning us into subservient
wage slaves and now people think going
to work means
misery like they just have like i have
to go to work well
work you're creating work if you pay
attention what work is in science it's
energy creation
it's measured it's worse than that you
know actually um sometimes
i have a nephew and i share talks with
him and i i speak to him a little bit i
try to
um undermine the conformity that gets
imposed on
folks like that in the public school
system i said hey
you know the company that builds your
school if you look around the
architecture of it
it's the same company that builds the
prison and they look exactly the same
there was a work same way there's a
little kid in chicago was thrown into a
padded room and locked the door and
walked away because he was having a
temper tantrum
they put him in solitary confinement and
then the kid just like cried and then
soiled his pants
that's that that's that's what's going
on and you know what it is these people
in cities that keep voting for the same
thing
so i look at this data showing the hyper
polarization the reds the red areas get
red or the blue areas get bluer
people who live in red areas who are
blue move to cities because they want to
be around
you know people who are blue and people
who live in cities who are red they move
to the countryside they get away from
the blue areas
hyper polarization is getting worse and
from this you'll end up with democrat
controlled super majorities in places
like california
where they burn the system to the ground
and people keep voting for it thinking
if we just keep sticking our hand in the
fire eventually it will stop burning
that's where we're at right now the only
thing i can see on the horizon
is chaos i've got i know people who have
been out of work for months
they can't pay their bills and they're
like i'm so angry with the democrats i'm
like
you voted for him okay look i i get it
it's not like the republicans are gonna
do anything for you
but what do you think is gonna happen
they're not going to help you
it's just going to get worse eventually
it doesn't matter what
side anyone's on their their heads are
going to figuratively explode
yeah that was the punishment in my high
school is it was solitary confinement
from eight to three they would just keep
you in a room
isolated by yourself can't talk to
anyone i actually held the record for
the most suspensions and consecutive
days
of like solitary confinement in school
but as you said you know they look
exactly the same they are exactly the
same like prisons
the rockefeller thing is something
important because he was in he was
instrumental in creating the modern
school day
which again resembles the modern day of
a factory worker
with exact breaks with exact work shifts
and and it's bell ringing
and exactly it's just meant to teach
people to rinse and repeat
rinse and compliance and then and then
homeschooling is something that's
attacked something that's looked down on
when in reality homeschooled kids
are getting a far better education than
those in public school trust me i went
to public school there's a reason i
still can't spell and mess
up my words daily it's not just the
polish but but when you compare american
schools to chinese schools
when you compare the intelligence levels
of of chinese people compared to
american people
we have something extremely worrisome
that's going to be affecting us
and i think there's a reason people keep
saying idiocracy is becoming more and
more of a documentary because it is
and they becoming a real life they did a
poll of young people in the us and china
and they asked them what they wanted to
be when they grew up
and people in the u.s said influencers
youtubers
instagram and kids in china said
astronauts
you know that's a i have a little
anecdote um i worked for eight years
as a mentor and tutor to inner city
children in dc
um and i would help them with their math
in english but also have one-on-one
sessions with them
um sort of these are kids who didn't
have like an adult male in their
household growing up right it's a
great program but i remember sitting in
front of the classroom
one day and just sort of talking about
the realism of careers and choices
i said okay who here is going to be a
you know what do you guys want to do
and overwhelmingly they were all either
going to be professional basketball
players
or professional football players and
when you have it in your mind you're
going to be a professional
of athlete suddenly the time you spend
after school doing your homework
oh that's a waste of time you want to be
on the court or practicing
etc etc not you know looking at the
realism
or the reality of how unlikely is right
whereas
getting a job as an accountant or some
other professional is
easily within reach if you just keep a
few things in line the problem is
we used to have apprenticeship we used
to have you know
you you're a guy and you're uh you you
work in a factory
and you your kid you know let's say
you're a blacksmith or whatever your kid
would watch and learn from you and then
pick up the trade and then the business
would stay in the family
and expand then we moved into the era of
the massive corporation where there are
mid-level jobs that you can't really
hand down to your kids
you know like the famous accountant
brought his kid to work to learn to be
an accountant doesn't really happen
then life stopped becoming about your
passions and what you were good at
and it became about finding some menial
task to build a machine
as we hyper-specialized everything it
made less sense to have our children be
an apprentice and they went to school to
work to essentially learn to be factory
workers with shifts and the bell would
ring and they'd get up and they'd move
to the next room
and that's where we're at now where
these people a lot of these people and i
can understand this
are snapping because they find no
meaning in these menial tasks
many of these people are becoming
communists thinking that while someone
else is doing work i should get a piece
of it
i'll tell you what you need to do you
need to roll up your sleeves go in the
backyard
start chopping lumber get fire going
cook your own food
grow your own food and just be
responsible for yourself for once in
your life but not only that
not only do the jobs that are available
or
are they cruddy do they suck but but
there's very little of them available
for the average person
and if they do have them there they
usually have to be countered with
social government programs like welfare
which of course companies like amazon
exploit heavily
which of course mcdonald's also does as
well which actually subsidizes
uh their workforce by american taxes
and and the local workforce that
actually does make a little bit of money
that is still
still out there but when we look at
robotics when we look at immigration
when we look at work visas
all of this is eliminating any
opportunity for economic
growth and economic prosperity in this
country and there's none left right but
maybe there's a plateau
like is everyone going to be elon musk
of course not but but when we're talking
about you know you know
jobs and opportunities it used to be
looked upon as as something that you
were proud of
now a lot of people who hate their jobs
hate
what they're doing and they don't want
to be doing it and they're not fulfilled
whether that is because of our
emotional manipulated state or whether
that is because of the larger social
economic
conditions i think it's both of those
things and i think there might be even a
third factor that we're not even
considering here
uh that we don't even know of yet but
essentially what we're seeing is a
miserable class of working people that
have been beat up that have been
assaulted
and have been thrown behind left behind
by the corporate establishment that
doesn't give a damn about well you know
what's driving this as you hit on it
is basically uh corporations
leaning on washington to allow
essentially unlimited illegal labor
across the border which is
cutting away a lot of those initial jobs
that people might have you say americans
don't want anymore okay fine you know
what job americans love doing
that they're told to learn to do is code
and yet you have these mega corporations
bending the rules every which away to
get every possible h1b visa of worker in
here etcetera etcetera which are doing
two things
it's driving down the wages and you have
people at disney world
who are running the i.t systems having
to train their own replacements
and their own senator marco rubio
doesn't do anything about it doesn't
raise an issue
and those not only is it driving wages
down but it's also driving
housing costs up which is one of the
biggest expense people's people have
and you can sort of see this explosion
in
work visas for professional jobs coming
into this country
and a steady decline of the median
income
of middle class americans just going
down and down down while you know at the
top you have
people like bezos etc exploding why
because they're exploiting
this beautiful market by bringing in
people whose
essentially did not help create it to
sort of more or less exploit them it's
essentially slave labor the
the most insidious thing about the learn
to code narrative
which they still pursue when now they're
talking about union jobs going well
maybe they can learn to code make solar
panels they're telling you
when they say learn to code they're
saying compete with people who live in
poland
romania ukraine places where the the
cost of living is substantially lower
and the amount of money that you need to
pay to somebody who works in
who's working out of ukraine is very
very low relative to someone else live
in the united states
the cost of living in the us an
apartment in new york city like you said
ian like three grand
that's the average cost of an apartment
in new york city i'm pretty sure well
now it's probably collapsed but for a
while it was
let's say you're only renting a room and
in a three bedroom three bedroom is
going to cost like 35 to 4 grand so
you're gonna be spending like a thousand
twelve hundred a month
you could pay half that to someone who
codes in ukraine
and they would be getting an average
wage making 600 bucks 600 bucks a month
so when these companies are outsourcing
you mention
h1b visas it's worse than that you can
just hire
all digital work for any company
anywhere in the world
it's that easy and it's there's a big
time value of it because you want people
working while you're sleeping you need
24 7 access on your
especially for for tech you need like an
indian branch
so that they can go six pm to see we
don't we used to use higher demand
people to work the night shift yeah we
called the graveyard which is ex but
what's making me think is that
what is the americans like the one
percent wealthiest people in the world
we have been if you have
making 30 000 a year in the top one
percent that's shifting now those
that one percent is coming from other
countries so these people in america are
swiftly becoming left behind
and may find themselves in the bottom 98
percent if they're not already
regular americans the rich are getting
richer yeah like people that whose
parents were totally fine
we're in the one percent they're not now
well look right i mean this is one of
the things that
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 p.m where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you